bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france association de commerçants et de
centres commerciaux qui publie une
tribune ensemble c'est assez inédit
c'est le signe là que l'heure est grave
c'est peut-être la première forme adam
vous avez raison de dire comme cela
nous nous sommes réunis plusieurs formes
de commerce que ce soit le grand
commerce e que ce soit les enseignes que
ce soit les indépendants nous disons non
à l'injustice non à l'hégémonie d'amazon
et des autres player jeu reprend les
propos de monsieur le ministre de
l'économie
il n'y a pas que amazon il y à alibaba
il y à d'autres pure player qui crée
dans cette période de kobe 19 ou les
commerçants administrativement ont été
obligés de fermer
et bien non on ne veut pas on ne peut
pas admettre cette distinction d'égalité
entre une forme de commerce physique la
forme de commerce de notre pays
celle qui apporte le lien social celle
qui apporte le rapprochement entre les
consommateurs et les commerçants se
celle qu'apporte la vie dans nos villes
sur notre territoire
alors qu amazon c'est du business c'est
amazon et les autres pure players il ne
se soumette à aucune règle
d'implantation et de fiscalité
c'est totalement anormal et nous
demandons à l'état de prendre ses
responsabilités et nous demandons bien
sûr la première chose que nous
souhaitons que nous demandons parce que
nous ne sommes pas en plus les plus
dangereux avec nos marchés ouverts et
bien c'est réouvrir à partir du 12
novembre dans le meilleur des cas et
avant le début décembre pour que les
fêtes de noël pour le commerce physique
ne soit pas complètement ruiné anéantis
au risque de faillites futures
c'est très très agréable si nous sommes
réunis mobiliser associés pour dire non
à l'hégémonie non à l'injustice dans les
formes de distribution
et bien c'est parce que nous voulons
sauver notre commerce
nous voulons et nous voulons bien sûr
qu'une convention de genève pour capa
soit dictée par le gouvernement pour
interdire de plats et khalid et
interdire toute promotion avant la fin
de l'année c'est scandaleux qu amazon 10
à ses clients un blake frye des
fantastiques avec des produits d'extrême
orient les autres avec des prix fenomeno
pendant le blind side et dire aux
consommateurs par rapport au marché du
jouet et bien acheté quatre fois en
quatre fois sans frais vous jouez pour
la noël
c'est véritablement une provocation
parce que j'ai des lendemains de cette
opération sur les commerçants en france
comment quel est l'impact de l'opération
du black friday sur les commerçants vous
représentez écoutez madame quand vous
avez un pure player ou des pure players
mais un coeur pays relâche et amazon qui
décide qui a décidé de mettre en place
un black friday pour profiter encore un
peu plus du combi 19 et bien c'est une
catastrophe ça vide de sa substance le
commerce de proximité quels qu'ils
soient d'ailleurs parce que les
indépendants les centres commerciaux les
associations de commerçants l'ont dit
ils sont réunis dans cette dans cette
tribune à laquelle je me suis associé
tout de suite parce que cette tribune
elle est essentielle pour lutter pour
protéger notre commerce physique
notre commerce de proximité il faut que
le combi 19 nous montre que des villes
sans commerces sont des villes mortes
précieux vous vous demandez donc la
réouverture des commerces a donnée
essentielle dès le 12 novembre le
ministre de l'économie
vous vous a répondu puisque il explique
qu'une réouverture ne pourra s'envisager
qu'avec de nouvelles règles sanitaires
qu'est ce que cela veut dire que vous
comprenez eh bien écoutez les nouvelles
règles sanitaires nous n'avons même pas
attendre les propos du proche du
ministre de l'économie ou du premier
ministre
nous lui demandons nous sommes les moins
dangereux et nous sommes encore prêts à
aller encore plus loin de là vu que nous
avons demandé pour justement protéger le
côté sanitaire que les grandes surfaces
françaises ne vendent pas des produits
non
nantes non alimentaire nous avons
souhaité qu' il y ait moins de monde
dans les grands magasins c'était anormal
que les grands magasins vendent tout
produit et que certains magasins de
proximité de centres villes soient
fermés bon on a obtenu satisfaction et
on remercie le premier ministre le
gouvernement d'avoir agi très vite et
bien là nous demandons au gouvernement
d'agir très vite et de lancer au mois de
décembre une grande campagne aux frais
de l'état pour dire venez au centre
ville sauf soutenez les commerçants de
centre-ville les indépendants et autres
formes de commerce
venez venez soutenez le commerce
physique c'est le grand mot qu'il faut
dire n'achetez pas que sur amazon et
chez les pure players
c'est incontestablement nécessaire les
les soumettre à l'équipe et
d'implantation et à l'équité fiscale
cela entraîne actuellement un tout
dernier mot au sujet des des ventes en
ligne que vous voulez voir restreinte
aux seuls produits de première nécessité
est ce que cela permettrait vraiment de
retrouver ce certain équilibre vous
parlais à l'instant
eh bien oui pour partie madame pourquoi
parce que on n'a pas attendu amazon et
je ne l'avais pas encore dit sur votre
antenne cet après midi nous n'avons pas
besoin d'être hébergé par amazon nous
n'en voulons pas
parise en surface d'ailleurs concernant
le numérique nous souhaitons nous
organiser nous nous organisons moi même
j'ai une plateforme numérique sous forme
coopérative nationale pour justement
permettre aux commerçants de vendre sur
le numérique de d'informer la clientèle
sous le numérique nous sommes assez
grands
nous avons l'aide de l'état avec des
vents moyens dans le temps de relance
qui ont été mises en place donc nous
n'avons pas à être hébergés nous n'avons
pas la main tendue vers le pdg d'amazon
qui a parlé il ya deux jours et je vais
été scandalisés quand ils paient 420
millions tempo sur 6 milliards et demi
de chiffre d'affaires je lance un appel
égale consommateurs à ne pas privilégier
cette forme de commerce ce serait la
mort du commerce physique élus lien
social dans notre pays
merci d'avoir prétendre ingère sur notre
antenne française palombes et président
de la confédération des commerçants de
francs
st